[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau débat consacré aux élections
municipales après Monceau Beaune et
Cosne-sur-Loire direction lionne ce soir
avec les candidats en lice à Avallon en
vue du second tour du scrutin avec nous
pour ce débat Jean-Yves collet bonsoir
bonsoir arrivé en tête au premier tour
avec
48,6% des voix vous êtes le maire
sortant d'Avalon candidat à votre propre
succession membre de la République en
marche mais vous avez souhaité mener une
liste sans étiquette je précise aussi
que vous êtes un ancien membre du Parti
socialiste Sonia patoure bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes tête de la liste arrivée en
seconde position avec
35,6% des voix au premier tour vous êtes
membre des républicains qui soutiennent
votre liste entre autres vous êtes
conseillère municipal et conseillère
départemental
Fanny Bouvier bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
candidate pour la première fois une
élection vous emmenez la liste du
rassemblement national arrivée en
troisième position avec 12% des voix le
quatrième de cette élection c'est
Christophe SPRINGO qui n'a pas pu ce
maintenir avec 3,9 % des électeurs il
menait la liste de Lutte Ouvrière
mesdames messieurs je vous propose
évidemment d'aborder cette
entre-deux-tours particulièrement long
fait de 15 semaines d'attente de crise
sanitaire de confinement et aussi
beaucoup de suspense parfois dans les
élections à venir jean-y College imagine
que votre quotidien de maire a
énormément évolué pendant cette période
je pense que c'était inédit pour tout le
monde que ce soit au conseil
départemental ou dans les mairies on a
pris cela comme un choc et comme
toujours quand un choc survient il met à
l'épreuve l'ensemble du système la
société l'économie mais aussi les
services évidemment les services de
soins en premier lieu et dans un premier
temps il aurait fallu faire face à
priori d'abord sur le problème sanitaire
informé s'assurer que l'hôpital et la
médecine de ville travaillent bien
ensemble mettre un lieu de consultation
à disposition par l'hôpital des médecins
de ville un lieu dédié organisé par la
suite les tests etc et puis assez
rapidement c'est aperçu que comme ça
durait fallait aussi que les services
vitaux continuent de fonctionner le
nettoyage la voirie la police municipale
les services sociaux tout ça en
respectant des règles de distanciation
de nos contacts en interne au début il y
a une forme d'incrédulité chez les gens
qui auront ça va passer il faut quand
même imposer les règles nouvelles et
puis ensuite on est passé aux phases de
déconfinement progressifs qui ont
demandé aussi pas mal d'organisations
dans les écoles les écoles le marché on
a petit à petit les restaurants ensuite
même si c'est eux qui ont pris en charge
en premier lieu mais enfin on a essayé
de de les aider aussi et puis cinéma
musée le cinéma c'est c'est lundi
prochain donc effectivement c'est
extrêmement particulier la priorité elle
s'impose à tout le monde et de façon
très naturelle tout le monde a mis la
campagne entre parenthèses du coup voilà
la campagne s'est arrêtée pour vous oui
oui Sonia patoura est-ce que vous avez
le même regard sur cette entre deux
tours est-ce qu'on était vraiment dans
le souci de la crise sanitaire et est-ce
que vous avez vous aussi arrêter votre
campagne dans un premier temps c'est
vrai que le sanitaire prend le dessus
sur toutes les questions mais très vite
arrivent derrière le volet économique et
le volet économique on aurait peut-être
pu l'aborder avec une réouverture de
marché un peu plus rapide avec des
éléments dynamiques un peu plus marqués
sur Avallon ce qui a peut-être un petit
peu manqué dans la gestion de cette
crise qui a été ma foi assez
administrative on l'a vu les
questionnaires pour les masques etc etc
on avait une gestion qui venait du
dessus qui s'appliquait sur la ville
peut-être qu'on a manqué je dis on parce
que tout le monde est concerné je dis on
a manqué peut-être de de prise en main
collective de cette crise en tant
proposition en tant que conseillère
municipal d'opposition vous avez été
associés par le maire parce que
finalement on est dans une situation
inédite il y a un entre deux tours une
crise sanitaire il y a trois candidats
enfin trois têtes de liste évidemment
beaucoup plus de candidats qui sont
partants pour un second tour qui n'a pas
lieu il y a une crise sanitaire on
aurait pu imaginer que vous soyez
associés
faites en tout cas en tant que
conseillère conseillère pardon municipal
et voilà non candidat non et conseillé
municipal non plus malheureusement on le
regrette c'est vrai qu'on le fait
repérer parce que dans ce genre de crise
sont toutes toutes les dynamiques qu'il
faut associer on avait aussi des choses
à apporter maintenant nous ne sommes pas
restés sans rien faire personnellement
je suis aussi conseillère départementale
deux jours après le confinement je
sollicitais le président du département
et je le mettais en garde sur un certain
nombre de points en tant que département
apprendre en compte je le sollicitais
aussi pour des choses qui se sont petit
à petit mises en place et accorder je
pense notamment aux primes qui vont être
versées pour les personnels qui
s'occupaient les assistantes familiales
vous voyez j'ai sollicité Domanys je
suis vice-présidente de Domanys là aussi
j'ai agi on a mis en place des appels
pour les personnes isolées ces personnes
ont reçu un certain nombre d'appels de
la part du bailleur social on a mis en
place des étalement pour le loyer on a
mis en place tout au moins arrêté mais
est-ce que vous faisiez quand même un
peu campagne à travers ça c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose très
difficile de faire campagne il est très
difficile en tout cas nous n'avions que
des moyens assez limités puisqu'ils
cantonnaient à l'électronique on va dire
à Internet peut on pouvait plus pendant
une certaine période rencontrée en tout
cas les habitants les habitants c'était
même difficile de les rencontrer puisque
la période de confinement éviter
évidemment toutes ces rencontres même
question à Fanny Bouvier cette entre
deux tours vous avez fait campagne la
vie démocratique et citoyenne a-t-elle
continuer selon vous oui bah sûrement
moi ça a continué sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment
avec la gestion de la crise au niveau du
maire qui a été totalement absent il
faisait quelques vidéos sur internet
mais il était pas la proximité de la
population c'est une réalité
non j'étais à Vallon j'ai passé mon
confinement à Vallon arrêter de me dire
ça ne sert à rien donc il a été
totalement absent au niveau des masques
il est il s'est réveillé 46 jours après
le début du confinement
c'était des masques qui devaient être
réservés sur internet donc qu'en est-il
des personnes âgées qui n'ont pas
internet ou pas de famille à proximité
donc ça te pose des questions et en plus
c'était uniquement un masque parfois et
qu'en est-il des autres personnes du
foyer totalement faux évidemment comme à
l'habitude avec le rassemblement
national j'ai la capture d'écran je vous
le montre à la fin voilà donc
à la demande du foyer un par personne
c'est peut-être marqué sur internet mais
moi je peux vous donner la liste des
masques qui ont été distribués ça
n'était pas un par foyer on demandait au
fond nous demandions au foyer nous
demandions au foyer le nombre de masques
dont ils avaient besoin voilà alors
Fanny Bouvier terminé sur votre analyse
de cette période donc c'était une
période donc monsieur collet restez
confiné comme la plupart des habitants
donc au début le marché était ouvert
sans protection et ensuite il a décidé
de le fermer
suite à ça donc il y a une réouverture
quand ça semblait être en cohérence avec
ce qui se passait actuellement
trois semaines après les autres d'autres
marchés étaient ouverts en tout cas sur
le département oui il y en a qui en ont
pas fermé mais c'était la responsabilité
tout à fait tout à fait ce qui veut dire
mais si vous voulez quand on a laissé un
marché ouvert après le 14 mars après le
15 mars il y a eu un marché les
conditions de déroulement on avait pris
quelques précautions de distanciation
manifestement inquiéter beaucoup de gens
en disant c'est pas normal etc le
lendemain d'ailleurs au niveau national
on a décidé que les marchés étaient
fermés sauf dérogation à ce moment là
j'ai décidé de fermer le marché et pour
que c'est une efficacité sanitaire il
fallait qu'il y ait une durée minimum
donc on a décidé une suspension d'un
mois vous savez que le temps de
contamination est de 15 jours donc on a
pensé que un mois ça faisait trois
marchés plein ça permettait de faire une
sorte de vie en termes de contact et il
a été réouvert ensuite avec des
précautions encore plus grandes avec
l'autorisation du préfet sur des
dérogation comme ça c'est fait ailleurs
et il s'est déroulé depuis dans des
conditions je pense satisfaisantes au
plan sanitaire pour revenir encore une
fois
sur ce que dit madame patoure qui n'est
pas faux nous n'avons pas réuni le
conseil municipal d'ailleurs nous ne
pouvions pas physiquement on
mais comme vous le savez nous avions
voté le budget avant ce que d'autres
communes n'avaient pas pu faire ce qui
nous permettait d'avoir les moyens pour
faire les achats nécessaires en ce qui
concerne les masques ils ont été
disponibles au premier jour du
déconfinement et ils ont été avant aussi
et ils ont été distribués en priorité au
service aux personnes des associations
qui étaient au service des plus démunis
puis ensuite bien entendu aux personnes
les plus âgées et enfin sur demande
parce que effectivement à l'époque déjà
certains s'en étaient confectionnés il
fallait répondre à la demande des gens
et non pas inondé pour des raisons qui
auraient pu paraître d'ailleurs un peu
démagogique des deux masques une
population on a distribué tranquillement
sans que d'attente parce que c'était
réservé sa m'était d'éviter des
attroupements des choses comme ça on va
d'ailleurs
on fait mais on pouvait choisir les
boîtes aux lettres on pouvait aussi
choisir parce que dans beaucoup de
harmonie officiel les cérémonies du
souvenir nous n'étions pas invités nous
n'aurions pas pu participer voilà donc
ça réaffirme je pense le rôle du maire
de façon plus globale maintenant dans le
cadre d'une campagne il est certain que
pour les autres candidats ce n'est pas
un avantage vous pensez la même chose
Fanny Bouvier
en valeur par rapport aux autres
candidats il a fait notamment des vidéos
à la réouverture du marché certaines
vidéos de propagande sur les gestes
barrières voilà donc oui il a été il a
été en valeur par rapport aux autres et
les habitants je pense qu'ils retiennent
vraiment vidéo de propagande ou rôle du
maire dans une situation de crise après
il n'était pas obligé de faire une vidéo
pour la réouverture du marché avec les
gestes barrières enfin c'est de la com
tout ça faut bien le dire j'étais pas là
mais tu es trop là non mais vous avez
fait juste une vidéo autrement pendant
le confinement on vous a pas vu ça c'est
clair
ça ne mérite pas de réponse alors tous
les jours
que Madame Bouvier ignore complètement
manifestement et je peux vous dire que
moi j'ai que des merci à dire au service
qu'il soit d'ailleurs municipaux au
départementaux tout ce qui travaille
dans ces cas-là ensemble ou à ce deux
manissent ça il y a pas de sujet
là-dessus je suis bien merci à dire aux
soignants j'ai dit merci à dire à
l'hôpital j'ai aussi des merci à dire à
la population parce que Madame Bouvier
nous sommes en confinement il s'agit pas
d'aller taper dans le dos des gens pour
discuter il s'agit de leur offrir des
services il s'agit que les rues soient
propres que les poubelles soient
ramassées
c'est la réalité monsieur je vous
propose quand même qu'on passe c'est
vrai les aspects sanitaires sont
extrêmement importantes
j'aimerais savoir Sonia patois puisque
vous avez pris la parole gardez la donc
est-ce que vous avez revu votre
programme est-ce que le diagnostic de
votre liste sur Avallon et ses réalités
à évoluer du fait de cette situation
sanitaire particulière et de et de se
confinement qu'on a connu alors avant
avant cette situation on avait tout de
même pointé du doigt des urgences
économiques existantes sur la vallée et
une action économique à mettre en oeuvre
alors vous allez me dire c'est pas la
commune c'est la communauté de communes
mais on sait bien que les élus
municipaux vont payer et donc
évidemment on aura à parler de cette
question économique cette crise a fait
apparaître des
urgences nouvelles notamment celles
liées au commerce celle liées au
maintien des petites entreprises qui
vont véritablement souffrir énormément
me demande c'est deux mois de mois et
demi de chiffre d'affaires effacé d'un
seul coup alors que les charges elle ne
s'effacent pas tout à fait même si on a
bénéficié du soutien de l'État du
soutien de diverses collectivités ce
qu'il faut c'est relancer une certaine
consommation une consommation locale une
consommation qui s'appuie sur nos
producteurs et nos commerçants locaux on
a besoin déjà de cette appui et ça ça ne
se fera pas sans les avalonner il faut
que les avalonner jouent le jeu prennent
bien conscience que leur acte d'achat
est quelque part un acte militant si je
puis dire il les entreprises de la
vallonnais auront besoin de de leur de
leurs achats voilà ça c'est c'est déjà
la première chose donc ce que j'ai ce
que j'ai proposé en communauté de
communes j'ai demandé très vite une
réunion de la commission économique de
la communauté de communes pour justement
travailler à ce soutien apporter aux
entreprises l'émission de chèque à
dépenser dans les commerces à wallonnés
peut-être une façon d'injecter un peu
d'argent dans cette économie
sans passer par la communauté de
communauté de communes communautés de
communes parce qu'il faut une échelle
tout de même assez pertinente et qui
puisse générer un certain chiffre
d'affaires aussi dans les boutiques
voilà ça ça fait partie des actions qui
me semblent primordial Fanning Bouvier
il va falloir relancer l'économie alors
que peut-être déjà par exemple dans le
cœur de ville les commerces pouvaient
avoir des difficultés par le passé oui
des difficultés donc il faut relancer
tout ça notamment ça peut être par la
baisse des charges notamment la SFE ça
peut être en incitant la population à
consommer dans le commerce de proximité
nous ce qu'on défend en ressemblant
national c'est ça c'est le localisme les
produits de première enfin de commerce
de proximité et ça vous pensez que cette
crise aidé les gens à prendre conscience
de ça oui ils ont pris conscience après
la population avalonnaise et un taux de
pauvreté avalan qui te 22% contre 14,7
dans l'Yonne donc ce qui est important
donc après comment voulez-vous que la
population puisse consommer dans les
commerces de centre-ville si elle n'a
pas assez d'argent pour finir les fins
de mois parce que les prix sont plus
chers que dans les grandes surfaces donc
il y a une concurrence voilà il faut
lutter aussi contre la pauvreté
l'économie c'est bien mais la population
si elle a pas d'argent on peut pas
consommer là où il faut consommer en
fait c'est un réel souci à Avallon et il
faut donc il faut inciter la population
à acheter des produits locaux ce qu'on
défend au rassemblement national il faut
arrêter de aussi de donner le monopole à
des je vous conseille notamment chiver
qui fait partie du CAC 40 et qui a le
monopole sur Avallon et qui paye ses
salariés au SMIC voilà donc à 15 SMIC on
ne peut pas survivre à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui enfin c'est très compliqué
de pouvoir consommer local et
comment on relance une économie qui peut
parfois dans ces villes moyennes être
déjà difficile et qui du fait de la
crise risque de souffrir encore plus si
vous voulez la crise agit comme un
révélateur de toute façon nous avions
déjà engagé des actions pour favoriser
la réimplantation de commerce de
centre-ville comme par exemple la
librairie ou comme un restaurant en
prenant en main de l'immobilier
d'entreprise autrement dit en prenant
les locaux à notre charge et on les sous
louant ce sont des choses qu'il faut
bien entendu amplifier
les loyers commerciaux absolument parce
que la crainte du propriétaire privé
c'est que le commerce ne dure pas donc
comme il a cette crainte il met un loyer
un petit peu élevé pour rentrer un peu
dans ses frais et du coup il pénalise
une certaine façon l'efficacité de ces
commerces là donc ça c'était en route il
faut l'amplifier bien entendu je pense
d'ailleurs que la communauté de communes
qui a une compétence en matière
d'immobilier d'entreprise pourrait et je
pense qu'on aura à y travailler parce
que ça va pas se régler demain en
septembre notamment avec la communauté
de communes je pense que ce serait des
moyens intéressants à mettre en oeuvre
pour abaisser les charges qui pèsent sur
ces petits entreprises alors qu'elles
soient artisanales ou commerciales nous
avions un programme physique qu'il faut
bien entendu poursuivre et puis on a eu
aussi des opportunités on a vu que les
commerçants qui mettaient en place des
systèmes de livraison de collecte de
pick and collect comme on dit en bon
français les circuits locaux ont trouvé
une clientèle nouvelle à cette occasion
et il faut essayer de les aider à
consolider cet attrait là parce que
effectivement la consommation locale
fait partie du dynamisme commercial
d'une petite ville centre comme la nôtre
qui offre des services
oui alors si vous voulez le revenu moyen
dans Avallon est bas nous avons une
population où les retraités sont assez
nombreux et le niveau des retraites
notamment dans le monde rural n'est pas
très élevé c'est vrai mais je pense que
il faut à la fois développer une
politique de solidarité comme par notre
boutique solidaire une politique d'aide
ciblée à l'énergie les choses comme ça
pour permettre un offrir des services
bon marché avoir des tarifs en fonction
des revenus pour l'école la cantine ça
fait partie de l'aide au pouvoir d'achat
le CCAS d'Avallon mais un million tous
les ans au service des plus démunis pour
assurer l'ensemble des services il faut
poursuivre bien entendu je doute je le
dis je doute que l'impact sur le chiffre
d'affaires des commerçants d'une
distribution de bon d'achat soit bien
réelle parce qu'il y a de la
substitution qui se fait c'est pour ça
que quand on en discute
c'est-à-dire que des gens qui auraient
fait les achats les feront avec le bon
d'achat mais n'en feront pas forcément
un peu plus
votre idée était comment dire à rejeté
en bloc je dis simplement qu'il faut
peut-être la cibler davantage que
simplement les gens en fonction du
chômage partiel
il y a deux volets dans cette idée la
première idée c'est en effet de cibler
les personnes qui ont subi le chômage
part le chômage partiel s'est mis en
route voilà c'est une proposition qui
est complète au chômage partiel avec des
niveaux de salaire relativement élevé
tout enfant que d'autres tout comme on
peut être au chômage partiel avec des
revenus assez bas et la perte de pouvoir
d'achat car engendrer ce covid il va
falloir la compenser c'est une façon de
la compenser et c'est une façon de
mettre de l'argent dans les commerces du
territoire les commerçants ont besoin
les commerçants ont besoin de faire du
chiffre d'affaires les commerçants ont
besoin de sortir de la TVA jusque là ils
étaient créditeurs en TVA ils ont besoin
de devenir débiteur et j'espère que le
mois de mai que le mois de juin leur
permettra de retrouver leur
initial qu'il faut cibler un petit peu
que cette aide sociale ne concerne pas
tout le monde c'est que par ailleurs la
Communauté de Communes n'a pas cette
compétence donc il faudra qu'on
travaille quelque chose c'est pour ça
que je l'ai apporté en commission de de
communauté de communes je souhaite que
cette idée soit travailler ainsi que
d'autres puisque ce sera notre urgence
il y en a d'autres il rien d'autre parce
que cette crise a permis quand même de
développer aussi j'aimerais qu'on en
aborde une autre celle de la santé par
exemple parce que on sait que nos
territoires ont parfois des déserts
médicaux en tous les cas pourraient le
devenir assez rapidement il y a la
question de l'hôpital ou du futur
hôpital il y a la question des médecins
libéraux et de leur implantation sur la
commune ou sur le secteur de la
vallonnais est-ce que vous là dedans
vous avez repéré durant cette crise des
choses à améliorer des choses à faire
évoluer pour les années à venir si vous
êtes élu maire Sonia patourey et Fanny
Bouvier là encore la crise n'a été
vraiment qu'un un révélateur un
révélateur d'une situation qui existante
sur tout le territoire avec des manques
manque de médecins c'est certain avec un
hôpital qui a pu assurer quelques Lico
vides en suivi et ma foi qui a plutôt
bien travaillé avec un personnel qui
s'est formé quelquefois un peu
rapidement voilà très dévoué et qui a
fait un bon travail qui n'a pas
forcément eu tout le matériel dont il
avait besoin dès le départ de la crise
et
comment dire qui a un peu travaillé on a
vu dans l'urgence mais qui n'était pas
dans l'urgence à ce moment-là bon
maintenant ce que je remarque et ce que
je souhaiterais sur vos propositions sur
ma proposition pour regarder un peu de
temps de parole
évidemment le développement de la
télémédecine on a vu arriver quand même
comme une une bombe ce besoin de
télémédecine qui évite le rapport à
l'autre tout ça c'est un projet à mener
en parallèle des projets départementaux
de fibre optique qui arrive dans le
département dans l'année 2021-2022 les
premiers déploiements ont déjà commencé
donc on voit que de toute façon cette
thématique de la télémédecine est
primordial pour nos
territorisateur on aura plus de médecins
en face de soi ou est-ce qu'on doit
continuer à essayer de faire venir des
médecins ça veut dire qu'en parallèle on
fait tout pour installer des médecins
sur territoire avalonnais pour cela il
faut coordonner les acteurs aujourd'hui
beaucoup de monde travaillent sur ce
sujet il y a les RS il y a le
département il y a le Petr il y a
évidemment les communes on a un grand
nombre d'acteurs qui chacun ont des
politiques à coordonnées le travail se
fait déjà entre certains acteurs mais on
a encore de la coordination à faire le
département mais chaque année un budget
important pour la formation de médecins
et pour les inciter à venir sur le
territoire
c'est un réel problème sur notre
territoire on voit qu'il y a pas de
médecins ce serait compliqué de trouver
un médecin généraliste ça crée du coup
un réel problème donc nous moi dans mon
programme j'avais mis la création d'une
d'une maison de santé avec des médecins
salariés à 35 heures parce qu'on sait
que maintenant les jeunes médecins ils
ont pas envie de travailler 70 heures
par semaine ils aiment bien travailler
en équipe et ça permettrait aussi s'ils
veulent pas s'installer à la campagne
d'habiter ailleurs mais de venir
travailler ici en fait salarié de la
commune on sait que ça existe dans
certains départements ce sont les
départements qui qui salarient certains
médecins vous voudriez le faire à
l'échelon communal tout à fait ça et il
faut les faire revenir aussi sur le
territoire vous qui êtes une candidate
âgée de 25 ans une jeune candidate
est-ce que les jeunes aujourd'hui et
notamment les étudiants peut-être les
étudiants en médecine ont vraiment envie
de s'installer ils ont pas envie d'aller
s'installer dans une petite ville où il
y a rien ça c'est un réel problème mais
pourquoi pas enfin après Dijon par
exemple ça a une heure de route d'Avalon
à faire tous les jours c'est faisable
les enseignants qui le font parce que
quand on est enseignant par rapport à un
médecin il y a il y a pas de manque
d'enseignants dans les milieux ruraux
parce qu'on leur impose un lieu de où
ils doivent enseigner pendant un certain
temps et ensuite ils peuvent changer
donc il faut remettre en fait au niveau
national quelque chose comme ça avec les
médecins voilà qu'on leur impose leurs
lieux pour une durée
j'arrive collé en imagine que dans les
prochains mois et les prochaines années
ça sera une préoccupation des habitants
d'Avallon comme d'ailleurs
ça l'est déjà on a constaté c'est ce que
disait madame patouré déjà dans
l'ensemble du territoire quelques
départs en retraite qui concentre la
demande médicale sur les praticiens
restants et donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
une pression de ce point de vue là nous
avons mis en place au niveau de nos
compétences un certain nombre de moyens
qui sont l'accueil par exemple de de
médecins à l'hôpital d'interne qui
n'était pas possible auparavant qui est
de redevenu possible nous avons cinq
internes en permanence ce sont des
jeunes médecins qui voient la vie dans
un établissement de proximité qui
peuvent être tentés de s'implanter nous
avons deux maisons de santé qui ont été
conçues dont l'une avec l'aide
d'ailleurs du département et qui nous
permet de fournir de bonnes conditions
d'accueil sur le salariat pour répondre
à Madame Bouvier c'est une question qui
est absolument ouverte d'ailleurs il
nous est déjà arrivé de proposer un
salariat soit avec l'hôpital soit avec
la collectivité pour l'instant ça
retrouver de sens et je voudrais dire
que moi j'ai été très frappé de
l'expérience de Saône-et-Loire ou le
département a pris un savon d'initiative
et si le département de l'Yonne se lance
dans une organisation de cette ceinture
vous pouvez être certain que le
territoire comme la ville d'Avalon
seront partenaires parce que ça peut
être effectivement une solution il y a
une petite remarque que je voudrais
faire une ville où il ne se passe rien
je laisse madame Bouvier la
responsabilité de ce propos ça tombe
bien parce que je voulais qu'on évoque
l'attractivité de la ville qui est un
problème c'est une ville qui perd des
habitants depuis de nombreuses années
depuis 40 ans sans discontinue Fanny
Bouvier c'est une vraie problématique
les jeunes on le disait pour les les
étudiants en médecine mais c'est vrai
pour les autres est-ce qu'ils ont
vraiment envie de s'installer à Avallon
cette ville où vous dites vous-même
qu'il ne se passe rien à relever ah le
problème c'est que lorsqu'on part faire
ses études à Dijon ou ailleurs à Paris
etc souvent les jeunes ils partent mais
ils viennent jamais parce que ils ont
trouvé
notre activité une dynamisme un
dynamique ailleurs et ça c'est un réel
problème en fait il faut montrer les
atouts de cette ville qui sont oui il y
a les atouts au niveau de la nature du
patrimoine voilà il fait bon vivre par
rapport à certaines villes du de la
région voilà il faut les attirer il faut
que ce soit une ville dynamique
attractive et pour ça il faut je pense
un maire qui soit plus jeune et qui a
envie en fait de se battre pour sa ville
parce que je pense que Monsieur coller
la ville d'Avalon ne l'intéresse pas
voilà il a d'autres préoccupations
ailleurs et je pense que les avalonnés
voilà il en a rien à faire en fait
Sonia padure est-ce que vous je crois
que savoir que vous pensez aussi que que
Monsieur Collet a des préoccupations
ailleurs mais
j'avais des oreilles
d'abord peut-être puis on va venir aux
questions politiques dans quelques
secondes sur l'attractivité vous avez
fait le constat vous-même c'est vrai que
la ville perds des habits
finalement coincé entre la Bourgogne et
l'Île-de-France alors tout à l'heure je
parlais de la fibre optique pour la
télémédecine bon évidemment ce n'est pas
le remède à tout mais la fibre permet
quand même un certain télétravail et
donc pourquoi pas de regagner une
attractivité sur la ville le tourisme
permet aussi de gagner des habitants
même temporaire en tout cas un certain
dynamisme et pour le tourisme j'aimerais
tout simplement qu'on travaille un peu
nos entrées de ville une entrée de ville
la plus belle avec une station
d'épuration trop visible bon je trouve
ça quelque part un peu ennuyeux une
autre entrée de ville avec un comment un
château d'eau un petit peu le crépis
c'est pareil je pense qu'on a beaucoup
pas faire on a la chance d'avoir
le château d'eau c'est pas nous le
comment dire nous avons la chance
d'avoir Vézelay patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO j'invite d'ailleurs tous ceux
qui vont nous regarder ce soir à revenir
à Vézelay cet été voilà Vézelay donc est
juste à côté d'Avalon à Vallon est une
base logistique pour vesley travaillons
nos entrées aussi pour d'une certaine
façon interface j'arrive collation cette
question de l'attractivité finalement
vous briguez un quatrième mandat mais
durant les trois premiers vous n'avez
pas réussi à enrayer cette perte de
population non elle a évolué on a connu
une période où les gens du centre-ville
partaient s'établir dans les communes
alentours c'était une époque d'ailleurs
où le département de l'Yonne globalement
gagné des habitants du fait du dynamisme
du Nord en particulier aujourd'hui la
situation a changé cette évolution
n'existe plus le la démographie d'Avalon
centre-ville continue de s'éroder moins
vite qu'il y a 15 20 ans où là il y
avait vraiment un exode vers les
communes rurales à côté
le département de l'Yonne lui père
globalement des habitants donc là dessus
si vous voulez on n'est pas en train de
gérer une sorte d'effectif pour n'avoir
plus que le voisin pour garder quels
sont nos forces qu'elles sont nos
faiblesses il y a des forces qui ont été
citées que nous partageons
l'environnement la qualité de vie bien
évidemment mais il y a aussi des
opportunités le numérique et le
télétravail ont été découverts par un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens
d'Île-de-France pendant ce confinement
il pourrait venir
ils ont expérimenté d'ailleurs les
capacités actuelles de très haut débit
qui existent par voie hertzienne et qui
seront complétés dans deux anges je
pense et à peu près ça par la fibre donc
nous avons déjà un FabLab un tiers-lieux
je pense que ces atouts là doivent être
cultivés ils font partie avec le
tourisme et les résidences secondaires
qui représentent 30% de la chalandise du
chiffre d'affaires de nos commerçants
est très très important je pense que
nous avons de beaux atouts et une
animation culturelle sportive avec plus
de 100 associations sportives qui je
pense pour ceux qui découvre mérite
d'être considéré il faut mener une
politique de notoriété nous faisons des
choses nous ne le faisons pas savoir
alors il faut aussi une politique de
notoriété pour faire savoir qu'il y a un
second tour de scrutin pour communicipal
le 28 juin prochain j'espère qu'on y
contribue parce qu'il y a un chiffre qui
est important c'est celui de
l'abstention
57,1% à Avallon au premier tour c'était
le 15 mars dernier alors comment fait-on
pour faire revenir les électeurs est-ce
qu'il faut qu'on soit plus clair pour
mieux comprendre qui vous êtes et
comment vous vous situez ma première
question elle est pour Jean-Yves collet
Jean Yves collet je ne vois pas autour
de la table de liste de gauche il y
avait une liste au premier tour de Lutte
Ouvrière est-ce que c'est vous la liste
de gauche l'ancien socialiste et qui est
passé à lrem et qui aujourd'hui vous
présenter sans étiquette peut-être pour
garder la liste sans étiquette moi
j'assume mes choix ils sont connus il y
a aucun doute là-dessus comme comme mon
histoire nous avons une liste qui est
composée pour moitié à peu près de gens
expérimentés dans ma liste précédente et
de gens nouveaux qui partagent des
valeurs de progrès la régularité si vous
voulez donner une étiquette globale à
cette liste qui n'a pas d'étiquette
politicienne au sens large mais nous
sommes dans ce camp de l'associal
démocratie progressiste ça ne gêne pas
l'étiquette lrem qui
mène une équipe qui mène au niveau
national une politique plutôt au centre
droit on peut dire dans une équipe ce
genre de choses se discute ça n'est pas
le tête de liste qui décide de donner ou
pas une étiquette nous sommes un groupe
nous avons débattu de ces questions et
si nous sommes engagés sur un programme
c'est parce que nous partageons cette
vision et cet engagement
vous c'est la droite et c'est la droite
dans la Rivier en plus vous l'avez
présenté tout à l'heure d'ailleurs comme
comme liste LR bon c'est pas tout à fait
le cas parce que j'ai pas dit
républicains soutenu par contre parti et
exactement mais c'est vrai que vous le
voyez aussi sur une liste dans une
petite ville comme Avallon vous savez on
rassemble on rassemble déjà très
différents parmi ces gens différents
certains pensent autrement et c'est tant
mieux puisque ça enrichit toujours un
projet sur ma liste j'ai quelqu'un
d'Europe Écologie
exactement exactement c'est une belle
ouverture d'esprit donc vous voyez que
c'est également assez divers d'une liste
très dite vous avez quelqu'un d'Europe
Écologie sur votre liste alors que
partout en France votre partie les
républicains fait barrage aux listes
d'Europe écologique y compris en
appelant à voter Martine Aubry à Lille
vous serez pas vous venez de me dire en
tout cas qu'il n'est plus donc vous
voyez l'exclusion s'est fait par par
d'autres moyens mais en tout cas c'est
quelqu'un qui apporte énormément à notre
projet donc il a sa place partout où il
le souhaite on parle beaucoup de de
l'omniprésence d'andrévilliers sur votre
liste est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
du devenu une difficulté alors que vous
pensiez au départ le député c'est ai-je
besoin de le préciser ça ne peut pas
être une difficulté avec quelqu'un comme
André Villiers qui impliquait dans la
vie avalonaise comme comme on peut le
voir dès que le de Colombie à Avallon
après
c'est curieux vous me parlez
d'omniprésence ça revient un petit peu
au thème de début de campagne où
Monsieur collet me disait que j'étais
une liste sans tête alors au début je me
suis sans tête sans cervelle peut-être
je cherchais un peu le lien on se
connaît trop pour que vous ayez pu
penser ça écoutez en tout cas je
comprenais plus très bien je ne
comprends voilà le sens de la tête de
liste mais la question de la tête de
liste c'est peut-être pas à moi qu'il
faut la poser mais vous monsieur coller
enfin c'est on connaît maintenant une
certaine nomination qui est tout à votre
honneur en tout cas en Andorre et moi ce
que je souhaiterais savoir est-ce que
bon nombre d'avalonnés souhaiterait
savoir ce soir c'est
Andorre ou Avallon avez-vous à choisi
que choisirez-vous on va dire tout de
suite vous n'avez pas été nommé coprince
d'andoratives non non
après avoir négocié la Constitution et
en être un des rédacteurs ce qui fait
que je connais un petit peu les textes
je vous répondrai simplement ça fait
depuis décembre que je suis magistrat au
Tribunal constitutionnel
la mère d'Avalon
il n'y a pas d'incompatibilité et tous
ceux qui vous racontent des choses
là-dessus sont à mon avis un tout petit
peu à côté de la plaque maintenant sur
le plan politique depuis 20 ans madame
patouré j'ai toujours dit que je m'étais
implanté engagé pour cette ville pour ce
territoire et que c'était ma priorité et
ça leur restera si jamais j'avais un
souci ce serait plutôt au cas où je
retrouve un mandat parlementaire par
exemple à la question serait tranché
autrement mais même dans ce cas-là je
trouverai le moyen de m'engager pour ma
ville et pour mon territoire d'une autre
façon alors ça y est je vous invite
quand même à regarder certains textes
dans ce concernant la nationalité
et pas ce que vous y pensez est-ce que
vous essayez de faire croire l'article
22 de la loi sur la nationalité non le
22 le 22 justement
économique et elle est liée à la
fonction si je suis magistrat je tuyau
d'Oran si je ne le suis pas je ne le
suis plus il n'y a aucune espèce de
difficulté si on m'avait dit qu'un jour
dans un débat sur Avallon je parlerai de
la Principauté d'Andor je ne l'aurais
pas cru Fanny
politique aussi parce que votre présence
au second tour bien sûr peut
éventuellement faciliter l'élection de
Jean-Yves colay donc moi je suis donc la
seule candidate qui affiche
politiquement enfin que je suis du RN
oui j'étais approchée par le parti de
Sonia patoure par ses colistiers
notamment qui m'ont appelé
parce que moi ça ne m'intéressait pas de
m'associer avec un parti LR écologiste
mais on a contacté Julien audoul
notamment et un autre qui s'est occupé
de la construction de ma liste pour
faire alliance on m'a proposé des choses
que je ne dirais pas alors là
j'ai honte pour eux voilà c'est tout
donc je ne dirais pas ce vous proposer
mais il était hors de question que je
retire ma liste parce que moi j'affiche
mon étiquette politique c'est pas tout à
fait pareil que vous parlez d'alliance à
aucun moment il n'a été question au
début on m'a proposé une alliance après
de retirer ma liste parce que les
colliers ne voulaient pas faire alliance
ORL avec l'ORL sauf que Monsieur André
Villiers lors des élections législatives
en 2017 il a pas craché sur les voies du
rassemblement national pour être élu
monsieur Villier il a été élu avec les
voix du rassemblement national
avec les voix des gens qui ont voté pour
lui je vais vous interrompre car c'est
le moment de votre minute de conclusion
mesdames messieurs on arrive au terme de
ce débat et on a choisi de vous laisser
7 minutes pour vous adresser aux
électeurs avec ce fameux sablier virtuel
qui est derrière moi et qui va s'égriner
pendant durant 60 secondes lors de votre
intervention et le tirage au sort a
d'abord désigné Fanny Bouvier je vous
laisse donc 1 minute après un entre deux
tour inédit de 15 semaines vous êtes
appelés à lire votre nouvelle équipe
municipale pour ces 6 prochaines années
je suis né Avallon j'ai grandi à Vallon
j'ai fait mes études même travailler et
j'y habite dans des plaises à Monsieur
collé côté coller c'est voté pour
continuer à déconstruire la ville
continuer à perdre des habitants
continuer à ne pas avoir de projets de
fond pour faire revivre à wallon mais
voter Sonia patouré c'est aussi voter
pour la continuité de Jean-Yves collet
et un programme vide de propositions si
les avalonnés ont à cœur d'avoir une
ville plus propre plus sûre plus
attractive plus dynamique et où la santé
ne passe pas au second plan s'il
souhaite Cavallon retrouve son éclat
d'antan s'il ne souhaite pas que leur
ville redevienne une ville fantôme alors
il faut voter pour la liste que je mène
la politique ce n'est pas une entreprise
c'est une mission d'écoute d'empathie et
d'action en faveur de la population je
m'y engagerai en tant que mère le
dimanche 28 juin votez pour la jeunesse
et l'espérance beauté Fanny Bouvier tête
de liste du rassemblement pour Avallon
merci Fanny Bouvier c'est maintenant à
vous Sonia patourey pour votre minute de
conclusion minute de conclusion donc
pour les avalonner et pour l'intérêt de
la ville puisque certes les élections
sont là mais ce qui nous importe à tous
autour de la table enfin je l'espère
c'est l'état de notre cité c'est son
avenir c'est ce que nous pouvons faire
en tout cas pour qu'elle aille mieux
certes la municipalité peut faire des
choses mais vous aussi en tant que en
tant qu'habitant vous devez vous devez
vous mobiliser pour votre ville votre
ville a besoin de vous tout comme nous
aurons besoin cette année d'accueillir
de nombreux touristes de nombreux
visiteurs des alentours donc cette
minute est une minute pour vous dire que
nous sommes à même moi et ma liste en
mesure de proposer un avenir économique
pour Avallon en mesure de préparer la
ville à des enjeux de territoire pour
passer cette crise pour passer toute
cette histoire qui bientôt sera derrière
nous mais nous devons pour se la réagir
réagir avec des moyens croisés réagir
avec des partenaires réagir avec des
entreprises réagir toujours dans
l'esprit de l'écologie merci Sonia
patouret et maintenant la minute de
conclusion à vous Jean-Yves collet comme
la désigné le tirage au sort et bien
écoutez le 28 juin prochain avec un peu
de décalage et une interruption liée à
une crise inédite vous aurez mes chers
collègues à faire le choix mes chers
compatriotes à faire un choix pour la
ville d'avant j'ai la chance d'animer
une belle équipe le citoyen solidaire
pour un ballon qui tout au long de la
campagne du premier tour vous a présenté
son programme un programme solide un
programme cohérent un programme financé
un programme dont la crise a révélé
quelques tressaillants particulièrement
pertinents qui vont nous demander encore
plus d'énergie sur le plan de la santé
sur le plan de la solidarité de la
transition numérique et écologique et
bien entendu de l'attractivité et du
développement économique de notre cité
cette équipe et son projet
sont liés par une même passion la
passion pour Avalon alors le 28 juin
prochain nous sommes tellement
impatients d'être au service de la ville
d'aimerait être fier de faire de vous
tous des ambassadeurs de notre projet de
notre cité je vous demande de confirmer
votre choix du premier tour et de nous
accorder votre confiance massivement
pour qu'enfin nous soyons au service de
la ville et de son territoire merci
Jean-Yves collet merci à tous les trois
d'avoir accepté ce débat place
maintenant au choix des électeurs ça
sera bien sûr le 28 juin prochain il
faut le rappeler merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis la campagne électorale se
poursuit sur France 3 prochain débat
lundi soir à 18h avec les têtes de liste
de varen Vauzelles dans la Nièvre restez
avec nous dans quelques minutes le 19 20
avec Arnaud Lefebvre belle soirée sur
France 3
[Musique]